any advice for a person with intense
chronic pain that wants to become who
wants to become a oh sorry it's switched
on me oh there we go
Crayola sheep says any advice for a
person with intense chronic pain who
wants to become a contributing member of
society specifically having the
self-discipline to push through pain to
take care of responsibilities well the
first thing I would say is that if you
have intense chronic pain then my heart
goes out to you because that's really
awful and so I think that you can cut
yourself a break I think the fact that
you want to become or continue being a
contributing member to society of
society as a testament to your fortitude
I guess the first thing I would ask you
is if your pain has been reasonably
managed you probably know this and I'm
not giving you any medical advice
because I can't but you might want to
note that there are antidepressants that
are quite effective as long-term pain
medications and you may already know
that but if you don't then you should
check that out because they're not
addictive and they can be a very
effective adjunct I would also say that
the literature on chronic pain tends to
indicate that more activity is better
than less and that and that's partly
because when you get engaged in
something that's meaningful let's say
and important to you that that activates
the dopaminergic system the same system
that cocaine activates and that can
produce a fairly pronounced analgesic
effect so I would say everything that
you can do to get yourself occupied with
things that you regard as important and
worthwhile is actually probably going to
help you manage your pain better it
looks like inactivity is a bad is bad
generally speaking for chronic pain I
mean obviously that's not the case if
the sort of activity that you're engaged
in is of the type that will aggravate an
underlying chronic physiological
condition but I would say make a plan
make a daily plan make a weekly plan
make it you know push yourself a little
bit farther than you can go comfortably
on a weekly basis and see how far you
can get any
year that's because what's your choice I
mean you're laying there suffering is
not preferable to doing things and
suffering not generally so I would say
like more power to you for trying and
but but also do keep in mind that
activity meaningful activity is a good
analgesic so Eric Butler says sheesh
Canadians never get it well I don't know
we get it sometimes Eric come on now you
know give us a break we're just
Canadians we're freezing to death half
the time so you know we do pretty well
given the fact that every day here in
the winter is the equivalent of a
national catastrophe in the US so
anyways Betsey Kirkland says if the
Second Amendment is taken away there
will be nothing to protect your freedom
of speech that is how important yes yes
well that is certainly the argument that
people who are motivated to protect the
second Amendment make and I'm not going
to oppose that so